oh well joined Now by Shadow Chief
secretary to the treasury at Pat
McFadden hi it's good to see you how's
the government done the right thing
well it's of course good to get our
diplomatic Representatives uh and staff
out but of course there are still uh
possibly several thousand uh UK citizens
uh left in Sudan and they're asking all
about us so I expect there'll be a
statement to the house of comments later
this afternoon are you asking for one uh
well we will ask for one but I think the
government will probably give one and I
think the key question uh in that
statement will be what about those who
are still left and what is the plan for
them how is support uh to be got to them
I understand the Practical difficulties
uh on the ground and of course you need
the right military advice about this but
the question will be what about those
who are still there what would you do
differently do you think as a government
well I think we'd be looking to those
who are still there first of all you've
got to try and find out who they all are
and uh and where they are in the country
and then I'd be asking uh the defense
Chiefs uh what can we do here what are
the practicalities we need to Diplomat
simpler to do that well you can have
your diplomats given support from
outside the country and I think the
situation probably was that the
diplomats weren't able to operate from
within the country so I don't think you
need them in country but I think you
need the proper advice on this
um but the question should be what can
we do to help those who are still there
um
what on Earth was Diana thinking about
well I can't put myself in our mind I
can only express a view on what she
wrote which was uh was wrong uh and it's
indisputable uh that for example when
she wrote the letter to the newspaper
yesterday it's indisputable uh that
Jewish people for example have suffered
terrible racism both in history and it's
still going on uh today so the chief
worker and the party reader had no
choice but to take the action that they
took yesterday do you think
she believed what she was writing
I think you can't put yourself in
someone's mind
but I think when it comes to the awful
history of racism
one thing we shouldn't do is try to
establish a hierarchy or suggest that
one group of people's experience somehow
counts
more than others of course but I mean
experiences may be different but the
point is what the party's been through
what on Earth was she thinking well look
I can't see what she was thinking but I
can see we've got to turn the page on
that kind of thinking when kirstalmer
became party leader three years ago he
was determined to Tom the page on the
culture that had come into the labor
party under the previous
leadership and we had terrible terrible
problem with anti-Semitism as you and
your viewers will be aware he's deeply
genuine about making that change he's
made the right response to the equality
and Human Rights Commission report that
came out a few weeks ago and said the
labor party had made huge progress
and we've got to make sure that we
underline that progress and that's why
yesterday's suspension had to happen do
you accept your apology
well I'm sure if she's made an apology
it's genuine uh but it will be for the
chief weapon the leader to decide what
happens next what do you give me said
what would you support
what I support is not having any kind of
hierarchy when it comes to uh discussing
racism and trying to you know what
should we be striving for that with all
the terrible history uh that has
affected people of different races and
creeds in this day and age can we not
treat everybody with equal human dignity
with no distinctions based on race or
Creed now that's a work in progress I'm
not saying what they are but that's what
we should be striving for and that's
what the labor party should stand for
Lord man was on the program this morning
he says that you should step down at the
next election well
the the way that this works in the labor
party is you are picked by your local
party you have to be approved by the NEC
the chief whip has a big c in that too
so there'll be a process there it's not
for me to decide who gets to be a
candidate but it is for me uh to see
what I think the labor party should
stand for and that's what I said in
response to your question a moment or
two ago you know when cure became leader
at the next election well look uh she
and the chief weapon the leader will
have to discuss that what's your decide
that my opinion is we need to have
firmly Turn the Page the page on the
culture because I don't decide who gets
to be here but you're entitled to your
opinion I know but I mean Lord Mann was
you know was very happy to tell us what
his opinion was you must have one look
my view is uh the views in her letter
were deeply wrong they were historically
wrong they are offensive to people uh
and that the labor party has to stand
for treating everybody with human
dignity regardless of race or Creed as a
lesson we should have learned a long
time ago and certainly one that we
should learn to do talk to me about what
it was like working with Gordon Brown
was he a bully I never witnessed
anything on that he's a tough guy Gordon
uh
he's never shouted in my uh you know in
a room I was in I've never seen him do
do that uh I haven't seen him throwing
anything no
apparently three phones and apparently a
photocopier
a photocopy apparently so well uh I
never witnessed anything like that uh
look Gordon uh was a robust character uh
certainly but I never witnessed anything
that you've just stated okay and are you
content that's what's happened with
Dominic Robb that he was a bully
well that's what the inquiry found on a
couple of counts and the thing that
Disturbed me about Dominic Robb's
response to this was this a statement he
made about activist civil servants and
the reason that disturbs me is because
uh having a civil service that serves
any government whether it's labor or
conservative and does so to the best of
its ability is really important and if
we get and he's not the first one to
suggest this if we get this notion among
conservative ministers that they're
going to start blaming Civil Service uh
blocking or being obstructive for their
own mistakes I think that's deeply
unhealthy for our democracy remember Mrs
Thatcher said advisors advise and
ministers decide she was right about
that but with that power of decision
also comes the obligation of
responsibility and he has to take
responsibility for his actions and not
try to blame the Civil Service
shouldn't stand at the next election not
uh that's a matter for the chief Whip
and a party leader okay it's good to see
you thanks very much indeed